[Musique]
pour le conseil en stratégie et en
organisation sans parler du conseil en
stratégie informatique rien que pour ça
entre 2018 2021 pendant le quinquennat
des maillots à crewe l'état a augmenté
son recours au cabinet de conseil privé
par un facteur 3,7 hier presque quatre
fois plus en 2021 qu'en 2018 qui était
déjà en augmentation par rapport à 2010
est donc il ya une augmentation très
forte qui manifestement une volonté
culturelle de ces gouvernements depuis
2018 et tout un élément tout série
d'éléments facilitant et il ya eu un peu
mais de façon très marginale les effets
de la crise sanitaire puisque la crise
sanitaire ses 41 millions de prestations
alors qu'en 2021 on a constaté 445
millions d'euros de dépenses en conseil
de stratégie et d'organisation
donc voilà c'est une tendance de fond
dont il s'agit
[Musique]
alors pourquoi recours à ces cabinets
privés d'abord je pense qu'il ya encore
une fois tout a été fait pour que le taf
à cincy alors qu'il a des compétences de
même je pense que l'état ne connaît pas
l'état de ses compétences et de leur
disponibilité
c'est à dire qu'on a des logiques de
silos ministère au service par service
avec une absence de mise en réseau et de
partage des compétences quand on en
aurait besoin ça les hauts
fonctionnaires nous l'ont dit beaucoup
se sont désolés qu'on n'ait pas fait
appel à mme sur certaines missions alors
qu'ils n'avaient partie parfaitement les
compétences donc c'est un sujet
d'organisation de l'état il ya un sujet
à explorer là-dessus clairement et puis
il ya aussi des compétences qui ont
disparu au sein de l'appareil de l'état
qui existait auparavant semble-t-il
c'est le résultat de nos auditions et
qui n'existe plus maintenant donc il ya
tout un processus de ré internalisation
des compétences à faire ça n'est pas
impossible l'ap-hp l'assistance
publique-hôpitaux de paris l'a fait
parce que monsieur vierges considéré à
son arrivée nous l'expliqué qui avait un
trop grand recours aux consultants et
que ça coûtait en effet cher peut-être
même un pognon on gagne et que je
pouvais le faire en interne et c'est ce
qu'ils ont mis en place
[Musique]
ça peut absolument pas être une façon de
gérer l'état dans la mesure où
l'administration apporte des garanties
neutralité dans la décision publique que
n'apporte pas des cabinets de conseil
privé chacun doit rester à sa place et
on a en effet souvent l'impression que à
travers l'exemple qu'on a étudié que les
cabinets privés vont loin au delà de ses
missions d'apport ponctuelles danalyse
mes armes le bras du décideur public en
quelque sorte par dessus
l'administration
[Musique]
alors nous avons fait une vingtaine de
propositions qui ont vocation à se
retrouver expertise bien sûr sous forme
législative dans une proposition de loi
la première chose c'est en finir avec
l'opacité des livrables qu'on puisse
reconnaître la mise en ligne d'un
certain nombre d'éléments etc ensuite il
faut encadrer le recours au cabinet de
conseil privé la troisième partie c'est
tout un ensemble de règles un peu
technique mais qui relèvent de la
déontologie
avec aussi ce qu'on appelle le
pantouflage c'est à dire le fait que des
hauts fonctionnaires travaillent ensuite
dans des cabinets de conseil ou le
contraire d'ailleurs et puis il ya un
dernier sujet de la question de la
protection des données puisque somme
toute les cabinets de conseil vendre des
comparaisons entre pays par exemple
notre région département et c'est sur la
base d'informations qu'ils ont
recueillies au préalable c'est un peu
leur fonds de commerce en partie et ça
suppose que ces deux nés là soit
suffisamment anonymisées pour que ça ne
pose pas de problème de confidentialité
et même de souveraineté pour le pays
tout